[Music]
sarah is with us sarah is in atlanta
georgia hi sarah welcome to the ramsay
show
hey thank you
um so my question my husband got some
stock options from a company he was
working for a few years ago
uh the money has gone from about a
hundred thousand to just got valued at a
million dollars a couple weeks ago
so we're trying to decide how much to
pull out of the company and how much to
leave in we anticipate it'll keep doing
pretty well but also don't want to be
messed up if we're wrong wow
what's your total net worth
uh uh
four uh probably like 600 and then this
600 besides this wow so way over half is
in this one company
yeah yeah we have a lot in it very
dangerous
yeah okay
because uh in other words you bet the
farm on this one company you went to a
horse race and you put your daddy's deed
for his farm on one horse
yeah that's right yeah that's scary
uh that's what they mean by bet the farm
now you don't want to do that so
um i don't buy single stocks at all
because of the risk of what we're
talking about the lack of
diversification
if someone is in love with their company
and their company stock and they want to
buy
some i recommend they not have more than
10 percent
of their net worth
tied up in
company stock and that means you would
have no more than 160 000 tied up in
this
okay
okay that didn't sound like to me you
were gonna sell that doesn't sound that
okay didn't sound like you were gonna
sell eight hundred thousand to me
ah that should sound like i will try to
convince my husband that that's what we
should do ah that's the tough part
he's getting started going but what if
this turns into 1.5 or two i mean we
could this is our retirement yeah
yeah exactly so yeah
where we've been and it's been working
out but it's getting a little big that's
what they said about bitcoin um
so the uh uh
another way you can talk to him about it
then because that's what you're trying
to do is to figure out how to discuss
this logically
the uh harvard investment newsletter
about 20 something years ago had a
beautiful article in it called sunk cost
analysis
and the danger of someone in your
situation is
that when you're analyzing you have a
million dollars in a stock and when
you're analyzing whether to keep it that
way or do something different
you are bringing into the analysis the
fact that you only paid 100 and some
change for it and it's grown to a
million over many years
it feels like found money in a sense
okay and that's an improv that is an
improper analysis by anyone's anyone in
the investment world even people that
disagree with me will tell you that's an
improper analysis the proper analysis
goes like this
pretend like you had a million dollars
piled in the middle of your kitchen
table right now in cash
and you did not own this stock
what would you do with that million
dollars would you go buy
this stock
with a million dollars off your kitchen
table
no you see how that feels different than
what i said earlier you need to get it
down to 160. and what that does is
here's what that triggers in your brain
here's the part of your critical
thinking skills that that force is you
can go ahead and discuss this whole
thing with your husband and you should
or play this back for him okay
it makes you and when you look at it
that way it makes you analyze nothing
about the past and only the future
and you say what what immediately goes
through your head before you went well
no i wouldn't do that what went through
your head was something like this okay i
don't want that much of my net worth
tied up in a single stock number one the
second thing is um i'm not that sure
that this company is that great
that i would put it all in this one
company
um
and uh you know
and you know i don't know i mean maybe i
would rather do something else with it
and all of a sudden the possibilities of
other things come across your eyelids
rather than just
uh oh i own this and it's awesome
okay so you can say you know it makes
you look for the only proper analysis of
an investment is forward-looking not
looking at how you got here where you
got the money is irrelevant what it does
in the future is the only thing you're
analyzing when you analyze whether i
keep it or not does that make sense
yes that does make sense that is a good
argument i might get somewhere with that
that's the sunk cost analysis in other
words whatever you paid for it doesn't
matter
let's pretend you paid pretend you paid
pretend you paid 2 million for it
and now it's worth a million
the same question will keep you from
you know because
that stock if it went from uh 2 million
to 1 million might go to 200 000
it could go on down right now that's not
happening with this company but this is
the reverse side of that same argument
if you're looking at a million dollars
and you're going well i'm going to wait
it comes back up because i paid 2
million for it a lot of people say stuff
like that right and if you do that that
sunk cost analysis that's a bad analysis
instead you say okay what do i really
think this is going to do only in the
future oh god i'm pretty sure it's going
to go down
well then why would you buy it and by
keeping it one more day you just bought
it again
you know it's the same has the same
exact effect on your balance sheet so
yeah if i'm in your shoes
knowing what i know from 30 years of
building wealth
and and i don't own any single stocks
i'm not mad about it i just don't buy
them i don't get tempted to count on my
own ego for picking one stock that's
going to be a home run i i don't own any
but if i did i would not own more than
10 of my net worth in a single stock so
in this situation dave this is going to
create a big taxable event if she sells
off this many shares
you obviously work with the tax advisor
on this but is there a strategy to go
we're going to stagger this out so it
doesn't you know shoot us into a million
dollar income a year
uh i mean you split over two years but
other than that no
you're gonna you're gonna get taxed on
it so you just put on the side a big
chunk of that money to pay the taxes you
know if you want to split over two years
you can
to reduce the pain and so sell some now
sell some more january 2.
but i mean you're waiting from now to
january 2 in this current market that
thing could go down yeah it scares me i
i
if i woke up this morning in her shoes
i'd be done with 800 000 of it by
morning well it feels a little bit like
you're at the casino and now you're up
900 thousand dollars yeah exactly we're
crushing it let's keep going and then
all of a sudden it can turn on a dime
exactly so that does scare me yeah that
me and you don't like losing money at
the casino we'll leave that to other
people it's easy for me to not lose
money at the casino because i don't go
so
um but the um
you know uh uh
it it's not the casino because it's not
gambling this is actually investing but
it can turn on you that fast with a
certain company and with a single cell
there's stuff going on at a company that
size that no one knows except five
people
that could the the news comes out
tomorrow on the ceo dot dot did this or
that my god all of a sudden the things
shareholders get spooked your millions
are half million yeah you know i
uh one of the saddest things i ever saw
in this was there's a
procter gamble which is a wonderful
company and i have no idea what their
stock is doing these days but years ago
i had a widow that had worked for
procter gamble 38 years that i was
coaching on money and um she came in and
she was just crying and she had put all
of her 401k money in png stock and it
was down 38 and so her 750 000 looked
like you know it looked like 400 000
and uh it was awful and she had lost
basically half of her retirement almost
because she had bet at all and she is
it's a wonderful big company but that
doesn't mean the stock is wonderful and
it certainly doesn't mean it's a great
vehicle for you to build wealth with you
can have a good company and even a stock
that's okay
or that has a good potential future
but none of them are good enough that i
want to bet my half of my net worth on
them yeah cool that's how scares are
you're never going to go public dave are
you no one's going to see the ramsay
stock hit the market anytime soon
because then that means you got to
report to the shareholders
uh that means a lot of stuff that i'm
not going to do yeah so sorry folks if
you're looking forward to the ramsey
stock it's not happening i you know it's
um it's it ram i can assure you it's
doing okay
it's uh it's doing just fine thank you
very much those um you get all the
voting around here that's it i am i am
the i'm the uh
sole arbitrator of stupidity and uh and
genius both so
there it goes it's worked out but yeah
it's i i
at least we know whose fault it was
right
one person in charge one person to blame
there we go